thanks for joining us America mark is in
Baltimore Maryland hey Mark how are you
let me try pushing the button again
there we go hey Mark how are you I'm
finding yourself better than I deserve
what's up well the reason I'm calling
today is to talk about bankruptcy so my
wife and I combined we have about a
hundred and thirty four thousand dollars
in debt a hundred thousand is student
loans and the balance would be credit
card debt we recently met with a
financial advisor and they suggested
that we file for bankruptcy because it
would take us a long time to pay off
that debt they suggested that saying
that it would be better for us to just
start fresh and I just wanted a second
opinion
what is your household incomes from I'll
combine it's about eighty-five okay do
you have any card debt car debt no we
know our cars are paid off okay
what are your cars worth um I would say
about twenty thousand combined okay all
right well here's the facts that the
quote unquote financial adviser didn't
know apparently or he wouldn't have
given you such stupid butt advice
student loans are not bankrupt a ball
yeah we did talk about that during the
conversations they never go away but he
was just thinking in terms of the amount
of credit card that we have file
bankruptcy will really have a man wait a
minute this [ __ ] suggested you're
bankrupt with thirty four thousand
dollars for the credit card debt with a
household income of eighty five thousand
that's absurd dude that's what I was
thinking
that's absurd because the bank that a
hundred thousand dollars for a student
loan doesn't change anything because
it's gonna be there regardless it's not
uncorruptible so we're dealing with
you're gonna file bankruptcy on $34,000
making 85 no you should pay it off in
one year every year yeah one year live
on 50 and pay it off in one year take
six extra jobs sell so much stuff you
can't breathe no eating out no vacations
and you're a hundred percent debt-free
in one year
what are your car is worth yeah cars are
worth what 20 okay each newer mine's a
little bit older so flappers working on
hers hers is worth what about 13,000
mine is about seven mm-hmm okay well you
can do what you want to do I if I woke
up in your shoes I have to tell you I've
worked with families that were in dire
straits over the years that were forced
into bankruptcy you're not one of those
if you choose to file bankruptcy it's
just because you're too dadgum lazy to
address the situation let's even say you
did it over two years it's only 17 five
a year and you're debt-free other than
your student loans
I'm not talking about the student loans
they'll be gone in one year I'm talking
about the credit card debt it'd be gone
in one year so how fast do normal people
that call the Dave Ramsey show that work
our plan
pay off a hundred and thirty four
thousand dollars making eighty five
about four years probably oh yeah that's
the normal routine for people around
here that would be student loans and
everything and you know I I would not
move down in car initially out of your
wife's car into a into a $6,000 or five
thousand dollar car initially I might
end up doing that as we go along we'll
see how it goes what do you do for a
living sir operations manager okay and
what does she do for a living
see the pastor okay all right cool does
she ever do any outside speaking for
money no weddings but that's about it
kind of does she do speaking oh yeah I
mean he says she speak on Sunday
mornings yeah I see that speak she
preaches Sunday okay all right I mean I
wonder if you know she might felt do
some pulpit fill-ins occasionally for
somebody that was ill or on sabbatical
or something in that congregation payer
a little bit or maybe she works an
evangelistic outreach and they pay her a
little bit for speaking skills or maybe
dot-dot-dot you do something I don't
know I mean if you add ten fifteen
thousand dollars a year to this equation
of income and you guys tighten down your
budget to nothing I mean nothing where
you have no life because we're gonna
clean this mess up you know you can
clean up the whole thing in four years
maybe three but for for sure and you
clear up those student loans really
really really fast as a part of that
equation I'm sorry that credit card debt
is a part of that equation really really
fast but you got to cut them up you got
to quit using them and you got to stop
living the way you've been living
because it's not working agreed I
understand
does that make sense yes and I yeah the
Bible says that no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness you guys make
good money so I know you're not stupid
people you're not dumb you're not dumb
you just been doing some dumb things
which makes you just like most of us I
did a lot of dumb things in my life dude
with money in particular and so I ended
up teaching this because I got a PhD in
D UMB but you know I don't know who it
was that gave you this advice but you
need to stay away from them because they
gave you really really bad advice that's
my opinion I think you can not only can
work through this I think you should
work through this I think it'll be a
testimony to God's power and your all's
life that you turn this around and that
you attack it and attack it and attack
it and that you can start having this
sense of self control this sense of
discipline and it will change your
marriage on communication levels it'll
lower the stress when you're working the
plan together and you can do anything
how old are you guys 28 I just turned 30
- excellent so when you're 36 and she's
32
you're debt-free how does that feel so
you said there's no life no vacations no
eating out for a short period until I
have for a short period of time you live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else think
about well how much how much money you
would have and how wealthy you could
become and how generous you could be if
you didn't have any payments right now
oh my gosh
think about the piece that would be on
your house the stress that would be gone
see it's worth it to pay a price to win
but there's a price to be paid dude
there's a price to be paid you gotta
you're in a hole and you don't get out
of a hole by jumping out usually you
climb out scratch and claw and pull and
dirt under your fingernails you know
what I'm saying you can do this man I'll
help you I'll help you I want you to go
through our nine week class on how to
handle money and I'm gonna pay for it
it's called Financial Peace University
you hold on and I'll have Kelly pick up
and we'll get you and your your wife
signed up I'll show you how to not file
bankruptcy you are not bankrupt not even
close
thanks for the call hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]